- [Julia] Thank you to
Brilliant for supporting PBS.
- Hey, hun?
- Yeah?
- What would you do
with a billion dollars?
I think I'd spend one
third on fighting poverty.
One third towards medical research,
and one third on reversing climate change.
- [Spaceship Operator] T minus five, four,
three, two, one, lift off.
- [Phillip] Woo!
- Philip?
- Yeah, what you said.
(upbeat music)
What does it mean to be a billionaire?
It's not someone who
makes a billion a year
or has a billion in cash
stored away somewhere,
like some people believe.
Instead, a billionaire is someone
whose net worth is at or above $1 billion.
Meaning, after subtracting
their debts and liabilities,
their assets add up to a billion or more.
Assets can include cash,
real estate, stocks,
and pretty much anything
that is valuable enough
to trade in for money.
- As of 2021, there are 2,755
billionaires in the world.
Which is 660, more than last year.
Their net worth can fluctuate,
but as of early November,
Elon Musk was in the top spot
with a staggering 307 billion.
He recently eclipsed the current runner-up
Amazon founder, Jeff Bezos.
Over the last year, these
men have made money so fast
that if they saw $1,000
lying on the ground,
it literally would not be
worth their time to bend down
and pick it up.
- Billionaires have
more money than anyone
could reasonably spend in a lifetime,
leading many to wonder is
it evil to be that rich?
This is a complicated question
that could cover several episodes.
And because it's about ethics,
it's fairly subjective.
But we'll look at some of the
main arguments in this debate,
give our thoughts and then let you decide.
- First, let's look at the wealth gap
between the richest and
poorest people in America.
Economic inequality more than
doubled between 1989 and 2016.
Jeff Bezos, Bill Gates and Warren Buffett,
collectively own more
wealth than the bottom half
of all American households.
That's more wealth held by three people
than by over 160 million.
During the first year of
the COVID-19 pandemic,
billionaires grew 54% richer
while the number of people
in poverty around the world
increased by over a hundred million.
- Some defenders of billionaires
argue that they deserve
their wealth because
of all add to society,
like job creation.
For instance, Amazon currently has
about 1.3 million
employees around the globe.
But are those jobs really new
or just shifted from the
thousands of small retailers
that have gone out of business
during Amazon's rise to dominance?
- While there's no way to
assign an exact amount of blame
for other companies' demise,
there is no doubt that giant retailers
like Amazon and Walmart
steer customers away
from smaller companies.
And whether you're a
billionaire business owner
or a billionaire hedge fund manager,
the easiest way to make
money is to ensure that
you are hiring as few people as possible
at wages that are as low as possible.
- According to the small
business administration,
firms with less than 500
employees are responsible
for creating almost half of new jobs.
So, even though giant
companies undoubtedly
add jobs to the economy, they
are by no means the only ones.
- Okay, so what about
innovation and convenience?
It's hard to deny that
Amazon has made shopping
a lot quicker and easier.
And if they're $386
billion in sales last year
is any indication,
the service Amazon
provides is quite popular.
Jeff Bezos certainly deserves
some credit for that,
but does he deserve all of it?
- After all, it's not like
he came up with the idea.
People have been predicting
the advent of online shopping
for decades.
The technology that finally
made it possible, the internet,
was originally developed
with taxpayer dollars.
And the physical infrastructure depends on
roads, bridges, electrical
grids, also paid for by taxes,
AKA you and me.
It's safe to say that if
Jeff had never been born,
we'd all still be buying
our books, batteries
and bug spray, online.
- We're not saying he
doesn't deserve to be rich,
he built a company that a
lot of people use and like,
which no one would do without
a financial incentive.
But when you take into
account just how many people
helped earn those billions,
it seems a bit lopsided.
- That's why some politicians are pushing
for a 70% income tax on the ultra wealthy,
to help close the inequality gap.
Now, that number might sound high,
but it's actually much
closer to what it was
between 1932 and 1981.
During that time, the top tax
rate never fell below 63%,
and rose as high as 94%.
Some are also pushing for
an additional wealth tax
of up to 6% on billionaires,
which would tax all
assets in their net worth.
- Sounds great in theory,
but there's no guarantee it would work,
since billionaires are
notorious for dodging taxes.
The lawyers, consultants and accountants
that make up the so-called
wealth defense industry,
can find tax breaks and
loopholes, hide money offshore,
and employ other tricks
that are technically legal,
but no doubt sketchy.
Bringing billionaires to
an income tax bill of,
well relatively zero.
- One of the sneakier ways
billionaires avoid taxes
is by taking out loans.
Yes, you heard that correctly.
The ultra wealthy borrow
money, lots of it.
Not because they need
to like regular people,
but because it allows them
to access their wealth
without technically producing income.
- Here's how it works.
If a billionaire takes out a huge salary,
they'll pay a 37% income
tax on a bulk of it.
Which is why so many of them
pay themselves low salaries.
For instance, Jeff Bezos's
base salary at Amazon in 2020
was $81,840.
His real wealth is in the value
of all the Amazon stock he owns,
which increases every year.
But if he ever sells any of that,
to say buy a boat or a new house,
he'd have to pay 20% in capital gains tax.
- [Phillip] Instead, what he
and many other billionaires do,
is take out low interest loans to finance
their luxurious lifestyles.
Loans are not considered income by the IRS
and they can even write off
the interest as a deduction.
When that loan comes due,
they'll take out another
one to pay the first one.
They can keep this going
basically until they die,
since who would ever deny
a loan to a billionaire?
- But let's assume for
the sake of argument
that there is a billionaire out there
who's paying their taxes
and not exploiting anyone.
Are they evil just for
having that much money
when there's so much
poverty, disease and calamity
in the world?
Well, not if they're helping
to do something about it.
And we can't deny,
there are some very
charitable billionaires.
Warren Buffett has given
$42 billion in his lifetime.
Bill and Melinda Gates
have given 30 billion.
Some billionaires have even given so much
that they're not billionaires anymore.
- But the fact of the matter is,
for every charitable billionaire,
there are far more hoarding their money.
Only 223 billionaires,
less than 10% of them,
have signed The Giving Pledge,
a promise to give away a
majority of their wealth
to charity or philanthropy
during their lifetime
or in their wills.
And Jeff Bezos is not one of them.
Though his ex wife McKenzie
Scott, did sign the pledge,
and has given away over 5
billion since their divorce,
leaving her with a paltry 55 billion. Sad.
- But even if every billionaire gave away
half their money to charity,
we're still letting a
handful of unelected people,
decide which causes are
worthwhile and which aren't.
Ideally, a representative
democracy like ours
would use taxes and
elections to give the people
at least some say in how our excess wealth
should be allocated.
- Don't get us wrong, the
issue is not black and white.
It's not like there's some
specific dollar amount
where a plucky entrepreneur
suddenly becomes
a scheming super villain.
Capitalism isn't perfect,
but it's a system that allows people
to reap the benefits of
their risks and hard work,
and has lifted millions out of poverty
in the last hundred years.
- That's why some economists say that
holding billionaires accountable
is actually a defense
of capitalism.
The scale of inequality in America today,
is virtually unprecedented.
When so many families are
struggling to make ends meet,
when so many schools and public programs
are starved for cash.
Meanwhile, half the nation's wealth
is being hoarded by a handful of people.
Well, that's when citizens
start to feel like
their economic system has failed them,
and they either want to fix
it or look for another one.
And that's our two cents.
- Hey before you go, PBS
Digital Studios and Two Cents
wants to hear from you.
- We do a survey every
year that helps us make
more of the stuff you wanna see.
You even get to vote
on potential new shows.
- Take the survey at the
link in the description
and let them know Two
Cents is your favorite.
- [Julia] Thank you to
Brilliant for supporting PBS.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM,
with hands-on interactive lessons.
You'll get to see math,
science and computer science
in a new way through visual examples.
Brilliant is for curious learners,
both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
For example, for those who want to
strengthen their knowledge
of probability and statistics
to better understand finance,
Brilliant's probabilities, statistics,
and finance learning path,
is a good fit for you.
It provides you with the fundamentals
of probability and statistics
to help quantify predictions.
Or you can jump ahead
into statistical modeling,
matrices and Markov chains that are used
in quantitative finance.
Brilliant will guide you through,
as you learn by doing,
the powerful mathematics and statistics
used to model the chaos
of the financial markets.
To learn more about Brilliant,
go to brilliant.org/twocents.
Thanks to our patrons
for keeping Two Cents
financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a Two Cents Patron.
For more about how wealth
affects your psychology,
check out our video: Does
Wealth Make You Meaner?
(upbeat music)